[Music]
Hey what is going on YouTube another day
another video some [ __ ] blowing up and
another video demonetized well support
the patreon it's so easy to do videos
now because everybody be making a big
deal out of nothing
a bunch of [ __ ] look I'm not gonna
lie man ever since I lost his weight man
I get cold
I started doing something recently that
I didn't know was it wasn't a myth
I started shivering that people don't
shiver [ __ ] body all shaking loose
change coming up a box and by the way
you guys already know I live in LA and
every time I say that I'm called
somebody who doesn't live in LA always
has to say some snarky comment about how
it's not really cold here that's not
cold that's like a Minnesota summer
[ __ ] I don't care what does your
perception of cold got to do with me
being cold right now I don't give a [ __ ]
but you chose to live next to white
walkers ladies if you didn't know when
it gets cold basically a man's penis
shrinks and our coin purse just triples
up inside our body after I go for a swim
my penis look like a laser pointer
battery and my boss said you look like
an angry walnut anyways onto today's
video topic we are going to talk about
the controversy behind Liz Oh showing
her big old beautiful cakes at a Lakers
game
first off before I say anything else
Liz oh I love you though you know what's
up good you too big you don't burn you
so basically what happened with all this
is that Liz oh is that a Lakers game you
know she's living it up having an
interview and then she's even hitting on
one of the Minnesota Timberwolves
players but during the performance where
the cheerleaders were going off her song
came on and during her song she's
decided to stand up and she had this
dress with the whole part of her ass cut
out and she started twerking his [ __ ]
well that [ __ ] was on a Jumbotron and
her jumbo cakes were being shown to a
bunch of kids
now people for alyssa in this situation
are saying that they don't really see
what the problem is right it's on brand
for her she's always promoted body
positivity it's not really outside of
character so what's really the big old
deal and plus when she walked in and
media was following her they actually
but you already knew she was wearing
that dress so why is everybody acting
like they're surprised now listen for me
I understand the whole body positivity
argument and she's just kind of doing
what she does because when I saw that
video when I saw her shaking her cakes
like I personally wasn't offended I was
just wondering why she decided to dress
up as Rikishi at a Lakers game Letta
but listen in my opinion that outfit was
ridiculous for a reason that she did it
on purpose
like listen we see people dressed up in
provocative clothing all day but that
was a regular ass dress with just the
booty cut out [ __ ] buddy
now here's my opinion about this whole
situation let's just break it down to
like the simplest explanation the issue
isn't about you ass and the twerking and
kind of who you are as a person is more
or less about the platform in which you
decide to do something and you telling
people that they have to be okay with it
when it's not your platform like I agree
with Liz and when she said this is who I
am this is what I've been doing since
day one and she did a whole Instagram
live about it but I think the the point
that she's missing is that this still
wasn't your platform the NBA a family
venue type of thing is not a platform
for you to do whatever you want they
still have their guidelines in which
they want people to behave there have
been people posting up [ __ ] like you
know when a white girl poses up her tits
nobody makes a [ __ ] big deal about it
but actually that's not really true
I've been at basketball games football
games baseball game for people have
either flashed somebody showed their
dick or did something crazy they got
kicked out
they got finally they got banned from
ever coming into that Stadium but the
difference is that lizzo is a celebrity
so people just kind of laugh about it
they talk about it but she's not gonna
get kicked out she's not gonna get fine
so I think that argument doesn't really
make sense the arguments that are being
made for her and the and the issue at
hand are two separate things you did it
at a very inappropriate stage and once
again she's also not a regular person
she's also celebrity so yeah what she
does is gonna get a lot more attention
but she already knew that what I see a
lot on the internet which I [ __ ] hate
is that when you guys try to [ __ ]
argue a point or you're trying to prove
something you completely ignore the
topic being discussed and instead you
try to gain popularity by talking about
irrelevant social justice issues to kind
of bolster that emotional support from
random people rather than discussing
what the topic is like have you ever had
a conversation with somebody that went
down like this hey bro you left all your
dishes in the scene yesterday do you
mind cleaning it all up tonight why do I
have to clean the dishes cuz it's your
dishes because I'm your slave and I can
do whatever you tell me to do first of
all you don't owe me and number two you
keep talking down to me like you all
mean we're gonna have a [ __ ] problem
looked up you could do you and you could
do whatever you want and inherently you
twerking in that dress isn't really a
problem is just the setting wasn't right
that's all I can make these YouTube
videos cursed up for storm and talk
about these topics however the [ __ ] I
want in this space but when I go to
church on Sundays
I'm not in there like no [ __ ] you what's
up Jesus sup homie bitch-ass Satan
[ __ ] so what do you guys think
about Liz out shaking her ass do you
actually think it's a body positivity
issue do you actually think it's a race
issue do you even think that people are
just trippin about nothing for me
personally I don't really care either
way what I'm saying is that I understand
the point that's being made when
somebody says that it's not really the
venue for her to do that
and that she did that on purpose and she
knew what she was doing and for her to
act like you know she's
Masami this is a little ridiculous
vessel I just broke anyways guys see you
all next time love you very much
and kiss my butthole peace